[Applause]
foreign
greetings kids welcome to another fat man
beyond I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark Bernard
hey oh Heaven's the [__] man welcome kids uh to
uh early afternoon early evening edition of the
show um normally we do this late and run late but
[__] no hell no no yeah we're and we're cursing
so grow up and deal with it um welcome back
kids we got so much to talk about uh including
the next time we do this show which is literally
gonna be on Friday night it's gonna be me and Mark
in the same place in that same place is smodcast
Castle Cinemas man that's right we're doing fat
man beyond live for the first time at smodcast
Castle cinemas as part of the Ides of Mark
Festival which begins on Wednesday as in New
Jersey tell them what we're watching Mark I will
we're watching even on Wednesday which is
the actual odds of March uh 15th at like
seven o'clock at night or something the original
Dune not the good one no some might say not the
dennyville new one but the actual uh the one
that David Lynch did but even David Lynch is
sometimes like kind of denies yeah I mean I've
seen the the Alan Smithy cut be like four hour
just assemblage of everything he shot I guess
that's the one that he doesn't really cop to
but I mean he still cops to the main one the
one that went out in theaters right he does
he does I I don't know how he feels about it but
he doesn't say he didn't make it uh that's March
15th that's Wednesday in two days that's podcast
Cinemas in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey uh me
and Mark will both be there and then afterwards
we're going to talk about it hell yeah [__]
stop us there's dark Nate's artwork the great
Nate Gonzalez did a piece for the Ides of Mark
uh so Wednesday night there we go with Dune uh
Thursday night shit's gonna get a little fire kids
reach of Thursday is what it means to be
young my friend oh my God excellent what
a great poll Thursday night is what it means
to be young we're gonna see Ellen aim [__]
in concert man um as we watch Streets of Fire the
uh the uh what was the [__] name who directed
that Walter Walter Hill Walter the great Walter
Hill great Walter Hill Diane Lane Billy Paxton
um Rick Moranis Willem Dafoe Michael perray
Amy Madigan listen to that cast everyone in
the audience like who the [__] are all
of those people the audience Superman's
mom's mom the Snyder verse um and uh that is
on Thursday night and then on Friday night
we've got Talent mark there's no reason
to be bored on Friday night because we are
going to [__] [__] City that's right
we're gonna watch Flash [__] Gordon
uh the one and only Flash Gordon we're gonna
unload the boar worms on you [__] oh [__]
um and then after that we're doing our very first
fat man beyond live from smartcastle tickets all
available right now at smodcastlescinemas.com
look at that art artwork I didn't understand
it and then dark Nate explained I was like what
is this Brokeback Mountain and he said no man
this is that [__] show that everybody but you
watches what is the show it's the last of us baby
and so we'll we'll save because I've I've thoughts
about the finale I thought about the last two
episodes but we'll save it for Friday we'll save
it for us being in person and people like this
show quite a bit right it's a massive hit for
HBO so I'm 8.2 million people watch the finale
um and I don't even think that's counting
definitely not counting the seven days
definitely not counting HBO Max so yeah man um
so that's that's what we're looking at kids today
of course we're going to talk about I finally saw
Ant-Man and we'll talk about maybe a little Mando
Taco I haven't watched the second episode but Mark
certainly has and I'm sure that uh Banff man has
watched it as well I don't know the F man was in
South by Southwest he might have been busy bamf
man get in here and say something bamf uh I did
I downloaded it on the iPad and I watched it on
the plane how is South by Southwest Banff man
was there working with The Hollywood Reporter
um which would call it as you can also get the
tickets on csmod.com kids uh I was saying it's
modcastlecinemas.com but uh will jumped in
to remind me that you could also get them
at csmod.com s-e-e-s-m-o-d.com tickets for uh
fat man beyond tickets for I think everything
probably anyway back to you how is South Pike um
a lot of work for me so I don't know I got some
barbecue that was good it's much better organized
uh then Sundance seemed to be that's my review
like uh the week before I went down there
it was kind of right before Southpaw began
for the Austin Film Society uh does the Texas
film Hall of Fame awards and uh they inducted
um friends of mine I I was the guy who presented
him and said these cats are amazing John and Janet
Pearson John Pearson sold clerks for us he
sold he was a producer's rep back in the day
uh he wrote the the indie film Bible Spike Mike
Slackers and dikes he uh sold Spike Lee's first
film she's got to have it he sold Roger and
me Michael Moore's first film and of course
he sold slacker which some people go that's
Richard linkler's first film technically not
he made a film before that called you can't
you can't learn to plow by reading a book or
something like that that's me being very nerdy
deep Cuts nerdy um so uh John was inducted as
was his good lady wife Janet Pearson who
for the last 15 years up until this year
ran the South by Southwest Film Festival she's
the one that built it into the contender that
it is now where it's like right there with
Sunday it's back in the day when she started
running it was Sundance and then down here was
South by and then she started bringing in huge
[__] movies and guests and stuff and now it's a
premier American Film Festival just like Sundance
everything everywhere all at once premiered
there last year and uh the d d movie this
year so it's yeah it's got Janet she was
the one that started bringing like the
big premieres there and stuff whether you like
Lena Dunham or not she's responsible for Lena
Dunham's career she brought in Tiny Furniture
and then she debuted girls there as well
um so there's a big TV element to it there's a
big interactive element music is still huge at
South by like it was it started as a music
festival first and then they added film
and then digital and internet and stuff like
that online but um so I went down there and
inducted those cats and also being inducted
was Jonathan Majors because he's from Texas
um and that was like the night that Creed opened
Creed Three um so I followed Kang on stage man
foreign he was abducted Margo Martindale
was inducted nice yeah she was just in
cocaine bear I guess and um Mike DeLuca
you know the executive who used to run new
line forever he was the guy responsible for
like Austin Powers getting made as well as
a gazillion really good movies Boogie
Nights and stuff but now he runs I
think he's Warner Brothers right or yeah
pretty high up at one Warner Brothers film
so uh he was um I'm hitting me some [__]
lavender kids still haven't smoked weed
tomorrow is seven weeks without smoking weed um
that's why the show's starting at three o'clock
nothing to do got no we just might as well do
a [__] show um on time no less uh but uh who
uh it was a pretty cool ceremony but that was
I was there right before South by began so JC
was out there working for The Hollywood Reporter
and stuff and uh he shot with uh DND cast right
dungeon dragons so did you have Chris Pine there
Chris Pine was there he did the entire interview
as a joke like he just made they were like how
did you feel about your costume and he just made
up a story about his costume that wasn't real
but he did it for like four minutes deadpan
wow look at him Michelle him uh Michelle Rodriguez
was my favorite though in like she showed up and
I had shot some stuff with her before but she
showed up with like no hair and makeup in like
like a wife beater and a puffy vest
and like yoga pants and she hadn't
wrote shaved her a lot oh I don't think
we're allowed to call them wife beaters
wife beaters I think we're back on
them tank tops small white tank tops
uh I just came from Texas it rubbed off on me um
yes but you came from like the liberal Enclave
of Texas let's be honest it's still Texas uh and
she hadn't shaved her armpits um and so but she
just doesn't care like she's so cool she just
is like I am who I am and it doesn't matter if
I'm doing press for the biggest movie of the
spring I'm just gonna show up the way I I am
I mean I'm not throwing I'm not throwing shade
but is is that the biggest movie of the spring
well I mean it's it's a big really I mean John
Wick four comes out a week after that which I
think is going to do better than it but even still
like she's also got fast X coming in may let me
tell you something I went to the movies last night
uh or yesterday afternoon uh to see Ant-Man try to
take my mind up [__] [__] and uh you know
we had [__] an hour straight of trailers the
first trailer I saw was the Nike movie with Ben
Affleck and that Ben Affleck directed and then
the next trailer was Flash with Ben Affleck
uh then the next trailer was Oppenheimer with
Matt Damon who was also in the [__] Nike trailer
with Ben Affleck then there was a fast X trailer
then there was a D and D trailer both had Michelle
Rodriguez and is that her name Michelle Rodriguez
like they got three actors in Hollywood and
they're in every [__] movie that's it like
it was so weird as I was watching it going like
man can't they spread this [__] around I mean
I know Ben and Matt have to be in the one movie
and stuff because Ben directed it I mean they
don't have to but makes sense um but Matt features
pretty prominently in the Oppenheimer trailer as
well I mean Jonathan majors has now cycled out
like his time in being the guy everywhere seems
to be over so guys let's let these other guys
take a take an inning or two let me tell you
it's going to be tonight Today's Show is majorly
about Majors because uh we're going to talk about
uh we'll be the last people in the world
talking about Ant-Man and then we'll also
talk about Creed 3 because I saw that and Mark
you saw Creed Three I saw Creed Three yeah man
you saw Creed Three you did everyone is we are
we're all up to date with Creed here we are have
you seen any of uh history of the World Part Two
not yet man I almost clicked on it last night but
uh my you know [__] Oscars was happening
so I felt some sort of responsibility as a
something somewhat of a member of the film
Community uh to pop in from time to time but like
it's so it's just so rough watching those
shows uh not not because I'm like no good
nominee for nothing but just like so like when
they you know bring up two people and they're
like movies are magic you know all that [__] all
that [__] before they read the actual nominees
like just lose it all man like just let them get
up there be like the nominees are and [__] off
but all that like you know each one reads a
paragraph about how [__] amazing Hollywood
it's got a little well I mean I I can I can
absorb that stuff and I guess we're gonna talk
about the Oscars for a little bit the thing this
ceremony had that none of them have had before
is in program advertisement like I don't ever
remember them saying hi I'm Melissa McCarthy
and I'm you know Chloe from from grownish I'm in
the new Little Mermaid so am I it's exciting for
us to be in the new Little Mermaid and thanks to
Disney and his 100th anniversary we're going to
show you the Little Mermaid trailer they're
standing on the Oscar's stage doing this you
know why that one works because it is [__] ABC
and Disney but then Warner Brothers had another
thing where it's [__] like Samuel L Jackson
and somebody else saying you know what no it's
Morgan Freeman it's Morgan Freeman it was like
Warner Brothers is great Warner Brothers is also
celebrating its 100th anniversary let's roll a
clip Montage of Warner Brothers stuff from the
Oscar stage like I've never seen them tossed to
a commercial for a movie studio from that stage
and then it went to other commercials I've just
never seen them sort of mortgage out that time
to just who paid for it okay it was um I
mean again like I'm happy for all the people
that want and [__] but you know at one point
like I watched the opening monologue which was
and then and then uh they were talking
about you know hey man the show is going
to be long because we put every category back
in this year like Wow That's mighty nice here
um but it don't have to be that long I mean
this is my hot take the Oscars don't have to
be that [__] long just just [__] get up there
read your read your cat read your nominees and
announce the winner and move the [__] on less
time of like a couple famous jackasses talking
about the magic of Hollywood Hollywood's biggest
night and more time for a [__] for one to say
some [__] like I saw the dude win for um for
the well I guess there's three of them and who
made the fat suit and the one guy got to talk and
then the lady goes to talk and they're like Bam
Bam and they're playing her off and you know
it's like I I would be so irritated if I was
the second or third person I tell you man I'd be
jockeying for position at that mic but they don't
have to do that if they've cut off like [__]
Margot Robbie and and and and Morgan Freeman
Morgan Freeman it's like I don't give a [__]
about this pre-written pattern [__] just like
you know you want to impress me let them go up
there and [__] fend for themselves and [__]
you know just make [__] up off the top of
their head never mind reading this [__]
this stuff about how great Hollywood is ugh but
um yeah that was my one take I didn't watch the
whole thing so much so that I was asking Mark
right before like what one best picture did
what did it did anything win yeah everything
everywhere all at once was the big and that was
expected and totally deserving it I don't know
if it was films I've ever seen I don't I don't
I don't think it was I think that that there
was a lot of consensus that tar was going to
be the big winner of the night they thought
that Caitlyn shed for sure was going to win
best actress they thought the movie was gonna be
in the best movie you know they thought that kihu
Kwan was probably going to win best supporting
actor but I think they felt that was about it
Maybe original screenplay but it really I am
going into it they had won the SAG Awards they
had them cleaning it up I mean Jamie Lee Curtis
was a total shock I I thought for sure that was
going to be for as much as I was invested in
this [__] believe me I wasn't like I talked
to my bookie an oddsmaker and I had it felt
like it was going to be Angela Bassett but uh
then it was Jamie Lee Curtis that one was kind
of surprising but it wasn't surprising to see
uh uh Short Round win uh no yeah it's I I
was talking to a couple of friends after the
ceremony who were like yeah Angela Bassett was
Rob and I'm like listen she did phenomenal work
in 15 minutes of that movie yeah but it's not
about the performance it's about the narrative
around the performance it's about the story that
you're telling to Hollywood along the awards Trail
and that's why Q Quan won because the guy who gave
up acting the guy who had you know was discovered
as a child and then never got a shot again and
comes back 30 years later and delivers great
stuff Jamie Lee Curtis has a great [__] story is
that I was a horror Queen silly comedies and who
just kind of vanished and was selling like poop
yogurt for a while this was my last [__] hurray
and so now I got I'm nominated for Knoxville
that's a great story Brendan Frazier is a great
story yeah Brandon Frazier is a great story is
a great story and Michelle yo was a great show
oh yo it's a great story yeah you're absolutely
right it's like if you had won an Oscar before you
were not going to win an Oscar that night and so
I ain't taking anything away from Jamie Lee Curtis
who I've always loved but like you know there's a
pretty tight category it was she walked away with
it was was kind of uh that was surprising to me I
ain't against it or anything but I was like well I
wouldn't have bet that I would have lost the Oscar
pool based on that one but I knew I would have won
with everything everywhere all at once like I saw
that movie when it first the week it came out and
is such a [__] crazy original movie so wonderful
I was happy to see that get awarded like crazy
um but what else won um All Quiet on
the Western Front did well and and what
is and that's a German movie somebody
said it's a German World War one movie
um based on a novel yeah I know I know the
book but I did not read in high school but
it was it was made by it was a German film so it
was enough for best picture or best foreign film
uh both yeah both up for both yeah that that movie
had two slots and clerks three couldn't have one
you had a great narrative man I guess man I
guess I got to go to Germany and make a movie
so I could get an American award I'm hitting
my [__] lavender Mark that really [__] did
start drinking this [__] you just want us
um what else one I mean I know the
song from RR one yes not do not do
um and uh I think we all kind of won though
because after everything all at once won
they strategically had Harrison Ford present the
award and kihu Kwan ran up and gave him a hug
so so there's shots all over the Internet of
him hugging Indiana Jones on top of him hugging
Harrison Ford last night so that's that's the win
I want to see that picture um is he is I thought
maybe a short round would pop up in in dial of
Destiny is that not a thing nobody knows I mean
in a world where he's like you know [__] on fire
after everything everywhere all at once I thought
somebody would do the smart thing and be like
oh my God put him in this dial of Destiny movie
and then make him the next Indiana Jones come on
just one and Oscar he's back right so in a world
where like you know they were talking to one
point about like maybe Chris Pratt could be the
new Indiana Jones how about not how about you make
Short Round the new Indiana Jones and let him have
a whole [__] movie that guy's got got years
mileage on that car I mean what what I want is
this Short Round Marcus Brody TV show Like Short
Round Marcus Brodie and Salah Marcus Brody's dead
right it's all he's young Marcus Brody it's young
Salah and it's middle-aged [__] kihu Kwan how do
you make that work he's [__] I don't know magic
but but no because because Temple of Doom is a
prequel that comes before Raiders and so you could
you could age that dude up it's probably not cute
one it's keyhook on remembering [__] but yeah
all right I'll take that yeah but I just I love
the because I don't think I don't think you're
gonna get a new Indiana Jones each time soon but
there's the whole rest of that [__] cast and so
like young daughtering gay Marcus Brody and [__]
svelte badass Salah like scouring the world
for [__] that they shouldn't put in museums
I watched that DK Daniel 01 and Chad said they
filmed Indy five before everything everywhere
all at once came out but still once you yeah
but come on reshoots they do that like [__]
you think that was the only time they shot that
movie so in that world I would have been like
oh my god let's get a [__] Short Round cameo
in here especially with you know it opens the
trailer opens with Salah talking so if you really
want [__] to appeal to somebody's nostalgia
if you don't put him in there it would be as big
of a crime as never putting Han Luke and Leia back
in the same scene while you have the chance like
why would you do it all anybody wanted man why
wouldn't you do it uh Tom C and Chad says kihu
Kwan as Short Round returning artifacts to their
original resting place to avoid curses assassins
Guardians that's not a bad idea right there
take it like it's Indiana Jones has died and
[__] he left everything a short round and
short rounds like I gotta put all this [__]
back if it's [__] like you know Ocean's 11
meets Indiana Jones where it's I gotta steal
[__] from like British museums and return
it back to the places that they just stolen
from oh that's [__] dope I've watched that
end credit scene is Shia LaBeouf sitting there
going he left it all to that kid what about me
what about Mutt and they're like well mutt you
shouldn't have said [__] about Steven Spielberg
yeah sit down shut up Gilbert did so wait did
the Fable men's win anything last night no
of a movie that wasn't clerk three that's
what I'll say um that final scene in [__]
Fable men's with uh David Lynch as
John Ford it was just [__] magical
I still re-watched that scene over and over again
I was surprised that that John Williams didn't get
the win just like sentimental like 92 years old
still working the most nominated person in the
history of the Oscars just this is the last
time guys what won best scorer um I think it
was I think it was All Quiet on the Western Front
what I think so Williams I think it was either it
was like I remember the fableman score but you're
right it's like this is come on man so isn't this
the last time he's doing or did he do templo dial
of Destiny I don't want to get the dollar destiny
uh he did themes for dial of Destiny it was
All Quiet on the Western Front yeah um but he
did say that he was retiring but he would come
back if Steven Spielberg asked him in the future
so it's like a soft retirement
uh composer uh Kabuki kid in chat
says composer volcker bertelman
won the Academy Award for best
score at the 2023 Oscars for his
musical accompaniment to the war film
remake All Quiet on the Western Front
uh Elvis win anything no um I don't think so
uh watch the movie before you get outraged
Kevin says Bruce are all quiet was a great
movie I'm not outraged I ain't outrage I got
[__] lavender right here I can be outraged
um I am kind of outraged that uh you know um I'm
not outraged at all are you kidding me you think
I got any skin in this [__] game they don't even
like me in this town we're in town for that matter
that's why I'm in Jersey well right now I'm not
but technically yeah that's why I'm usually in
Jersey now but uh no I just felt like in a world
of narratives right where [__] Mark was talking
about like hey it's a great story for Jamie Lee
Curtis to his great story for kiwanda it would
have been a great story for John Williams to win
yeah that's that's where I would have put my money
um somebody said that um uh they showed a piece
of yoga hosers in the pre-show because of Austin
Butler because he was in yoga losers that's
the closest I've ever gotten to the [__]
Oscars shy of Ben and Matt who won for Goodwill
Hunting and promptly forget to thank me and Scott
um Hollywood night I spent most of it going
between the ceremony and then watching Saturday
Night Live clips from the Jenna Ortega episode
did you happen to see any of it I haven't seen
it now you did one uh [__] funny sketch called
like School versus school or something like that
on PBS I don't know if it's a real show or not
but the idea is like uh teachers and their best
students face off against other schools and um
you know for there was one school is like from
New Jersey or some [__] and the other school was
like Professor Zander's school for gifted children
it was kind of like and they had uh Mikey day like
bald skin in [__] the yellow cartoon wheelchair
and they also had Jenna Ortega essentially playing
a version of Rogue um but it was pretty funny man
it was a good sketch I don't know why they didn't
just go for it and say they're X-Men why they or
you know I didn't know why I didn't I didn't see
the point and like kind of renaming them but you
knew exactly who they were it was pretty funny
yeah satire is your friend guys just said with
the X-Men what are they were either gonna get sued
by Disney Disney was too busy [__] promoting the
[__] out of itself all over its Oscar cast have
you met have we mentioned it were Disney no man
um well congratulations to all the [__] Oscar
winners I'm sure your lives are so much better now
um it says hello a wonderful moment when they
get up there and like thank their parents
or like you know this is for everybody
that looks like me and stuff like that
that part up I I wish it would the Oscar
cast is just the [__] accepted speeches
that's that's where it's emotional and we only
really care when it's emotional that's truly man
like let them get up there and [__] tear their
hearts out rip your hearts out in the process
talking about how long it took to get there and
the dreams and stuff on was just like you know
it thanked his wife because you know she was like
your day's coming which I'll be honest with you
like [__] who could have seen that she must be
a magician like seriously like if you ever would
have guessed like you know was the guy who was
in [__] in the Temple of Doom and Goonies one
day gonna win an Oscar like years down decades
later so his his wife is a uh what do they call
that [__] when you could see into the future
prognosticator I was gonna use that word but that
seems a little technical isn't there more it's not
as much fun she's not a Seer there you go see her
um what were they in the [__] the three witches
and uh in Macbeth I mean there's witches man
you said it right there there are three witches
what they call them is it witches Rich Williams
says sober Kevin is all loving as Stone
Kev yeah we'll see when I review Ant-Man
um yes he is Clairvoyant somebody said Clairvoyant
yeah I'll take that or an oracle that's what I was
looking for or Oracle uh the the witches
are called the fates diviners his wife is
a an oracle a diviner she's prescient somebody
else pointed out it's an irregular spectacular
um Samuel Bankston said clerks
three was just depressing yeah
yeah because life is [__] depressing you want
to get yourself a bottle of lavender buddy I
love clerks three uh I watched you know we just
had last weekend uh clerks open all night that's
what we did at the theater on Friday night so
from like midnight till seven in the morning
we had a full house and we watched clerks and
then clerks too and clerks three in between each
one we were auctioning off stuff and whatnot but I
watched all three movies back to back to back and
watched everybody age with the exception of yours
truly who actually aged a little bit backwards
that's the the you know if you lose
weight you just that's what happens
you just look younger for some reason
um so yeah I watched Silent Bob go from
old to older to younger than the two of them
uh but man what a good time we had and then
the next night we had the premiere of
a horror film called The Forest Hills
uh directed by Scott Goldberg and uh he had
Eddie Furlong was in it so he came out he was
um and we had and Shelley Duvall is in it so she
zoomed in um for the Post show discussion q a
and uh I was you know kind of Hosting but
also trying to let Scott be his own host
um but at one point Shelley Duvall like [__]
talked about she's like it was nice to have a
director who wasn't trying to kill me and I wanted
to mine that because I should know what she's
talking about she's talking about the bathroom
that Mark's in right now The Shining bathroom
and [__] she's talking about how like on The
Shining if you've never seen that making of The
Shining documentary like uh Kubrick was not kind
to that woman you know I think she was referencing
that can't imagine she was talking about Robert
Altman and Popeye that son of a [__] bring up
Altman and stuff and somebody was like Popeye I
was like well yeah and Nashville but yes Popeye
um is the movie about the neighborhood in Queens
Forest Hills it's not it's about it's the Forest
Hills and it's about it's a werewolf story okay
or is it that's kind of the point of the movie
um but the uh the the post show discussion
was good she also referenced real quickly
and I wanted to follow up on that but
then they uh chucked them all off soon
that Francis Ford Coppola wanted to do an
episode of fairy tale theater which was a show
that Shelley Duvall like single-handedly [__]
produced for Showtime back in the day that um had
a bunch of famous people doing [__] fairy tales
and stuff she said Coppola wanted to Direct One
just so he could work with video because they shot
the whole thing like on video as opposed to film
and uh I thought that was interesting and then
that topic kind of went away but uh that's what
we did at smod Castle last weekend this week of
course as previously mentioned when we started
the show and if you didn't hear it and you're
coming in late this Wednesday starts the Ides
of Mark that's modcastle Cinemas me and Mark
Bernardin this way me and Mark me and Mark
Bernard I'm never good at this um are going to
be at smodcast Castle showing a mini 80s Film
Festival that starts with Dune uh the one true
Dune by David Lynch that's on Wednesday night
on Thursday night we're watching Streets of
Fire with Superman's mom Diane Lane and then
on Friday night flash lightning bolt ah wow
yeah Flash Gordon with [__] Queen score
um and then after that we're doing
our very first fat man beyond live
from Smock housing Cinema so this ain't the only
fat man beyond you're gonna see this week kids
no and that is the first fat man Beyond Live we've
done on the Eastern Seaboard I was I I was gonna I
yeah on the Eastern seabird we went further east
and did it in England once we did we did one in
London and we did one in what was that Saint John
was that it the one that's up in Canada yeah up
in Canada in Nova Scotia Nova Scotia um we also
did one at the other little smog Castle next to
um the quick stop and you zoomed in you weren't
there but this is the first time we're doing it
together you want to go to any of that you want
to see Dune with me and Mark and then talk about
it afterwards you want to watch Streets of Fire
you want to sing along Streets of Fire feel it
in your soul tonight is what it means to be young
you want to [__] watch Flash Gordon or watch Us
flash our Gordons when we do [__] fat man beyond
afterwards go get tickets right now at csmod.com
horse mod castlecinemas.com would you like to know
which movie is selling best oh I would it's easy
to tell because the two of them are on a Wednesday
and Thursday and the one on Friday is selling best
now there could just be people like [__]
I want to see Flash Gordon on the big screen
um but Flash Gordon's outsawing the other two
uh by by like double numbers and [__] Batman
Beyond is out selling all of them nice I mean
I wonder if it's because and did we talk about
it last week are we supposed to talk about it
this week um topple the fella who played hands
zarkov passed away did he he did he did
of a long time Fiddler on the Roof he was
um yeah no he passed away from uh Alzheimer's
complications from Alzheimer's oh man
yeah it's no [__] good way out of this
life could you imagine you're the star of
[__] Fiddler on the Roof and you also get to
play uh doctor what's his name you're playing
Dr zarko Argo you're playing Dr zarkov and
you're like [__] hey I'll never die and
then one day you [__] die it ain't fair oh
I guess that's why I gotta appreciate people
um while they're here absolutely and
you gotta appreciate every moment man
every moment passes you don't get it
back and we tend to forget that like
it all ends Memento Mori kids something they used
to put on Settlers Graves uh it means remember
you must die that's how we should begin and end
every show [__] Jeff's kiss should be Memento
Mori and it's not meant to be like crimson
and [__] it's meant to remind you that like
this ain't no day is promised and [__] tomorrow
may not happen so [__] remember you must die
and then sometimes I think uh I tend to forget
that all the time but oh yeah it's gonna all
stop isn't it I just think it's gonna go on and
on I think I'm gonna I think year after year I'm
just gonna continue to be ignored by the academy
until one day but I think uh yeah I gotta remember
all the time that it [__] all comes to a close
doesn't it I just remember that from the title of
an X-Files episode yeah Mento Mori was the episode
that's right it was Scully was looking for her the
the origin story behind her dad's death I believe
that is um that's some deep Cuts right there ain't
nobody talking about the X-Files but us kids you
tuned in to [__] watch him talk about Ant-Man
take a back seat to our discussions about the
X-Files season five episode three Memento is your
favorite what's your favorite X-Files episode one
of mine is hands down Clive Clyde ruckman's final
Repose I still talk about like you know when he
Peter Boyle who is so wonderful in it plays this
guy who could like see how people are gonna die
and he's he's talking to Mulder and and you know
Fox mull is like well how do I die and he goes
well I'm not going to tell you he's going but
All I'm gonna say is audio autoerotica
asphyxiation is a really [__] sad way to
go it's funny because like part of Mulder's
storyline was he loved pornography yep
um and then even better than that is like
he's trying to tell Scully and scully's
like I don't want to hear it and then finally
she turns around she's like all right how do I
die and Peter Boyle goes you don't it was such
a [__] awesome moment it means like she she
never dies she'll never get older she never
dies she's in raccoon 4 man she's a Brimley
um I love that one I loved um pusher
if you remember that one it was a guy who could
push thoughts into other people's minds yeah
um I thought that was freakish as [__] and
then beyond the sea where scully's Dad dies
but first they're visiting her and then her
her dad and her mom and then they leave and
then she's fall asleep watching TV and she wakes
up and she sees her father sitting in the chair
across her and she's like confused she's like oh
my God you guys came back and he's just going like
he's talking but you can't hear him and [__]
and then the phone rings and she goes to answer
it and she turns around and he's not there anymore
and they tell him like dad just died and stuff
um and that's where they go see Brad Dourif
remember he plays that guy in jail where he's
like spontaneous combustion no no no that's the
one where he's the guy who he's the killer who he
says like at one point he calls her Starbuck and
[__] and he's saying that Dad is in him as well
um he's the not Monty Props Monty Props
is the guy I don't think they ever did
an episode with him but remember in the first
episode of X-Files you know she's like they're
like are you familiar with Fox Mulder and she's
like yeah he's the one that wrote the Biograph
on Monty Props that got him killed the profile on
Monty Props that got him captured he was a serial
killer they should [__] do that man maybe
they did maybe I missed that episode but like
I like talking about it
makes me want to re-watch it
but that's a lot of [__] X-Files like there was
like 11 seasons and what was the one that where oh
um oh Jose Chung's from outer space was that
what it was with uh Tribeca and Ventura yeah
Jesse The Body as Men In Black that was a great
episode too uh that was the one with um like
like where they're telling the story and and the
one guy like the one cop in the town has a real
mouth and and like dirty mouth and he he flat out
says he goes what the bleep is bleeping going on
um all right you know what [__] enough of this
[__] should we sell some [__] yeah hey kids
you know we got a sponsor and it's a wonderful
sponsor because this sponsor has been with us
the whole the whole ride the whole the like family
as they say in those movies that I don't watch
um which I saw a trailer for Fast X and I was like
it seems like they got their own thing going
on yeah they figured out their own thing
um it was weird it was like it's it's so
strange to be somebody who spends so much time
enmeshed with pop culture but like those movies
I've I've completely missed those movies all of
them so as I was watching this Trail and they're
like ride or die man like one last ride what is
this meant to be the last one uh I think there's
two more I think there's fast X and then there's
whatever the last one is going to be called
last 11 yes fast to Heaven what do I know they
seem to be doing very well um you know who's
doing very well kids tell us Folks at native
nativedeo.com here do me a favor why don't you go
to nativedeo.com Fatman right now to follow along
because you could use the promo code fat man at
checkout you can get a sweet 20 off your first
order man that's nativedeo.com Batman or use that
promo code Fatman a checkout you get 20 of your
first order but if you're like wait what is native
well let me tell you native they make they make
amazing deodorants just amazing deodorants as
well as other things man but like the deodorant
like they make skin wash and hair wash and skin
wash is that a thing body wash I guess so laughs
they have a candy kit going on right now um
they've got this Limited Edition Candy Shop
collection um featuring gummy bears you want
to smell like gummy bears under your armpits
like you can smell like gummy bears there
well a you could stick one there but that's
gross or you can use the native Deo version
of it they got strawberry and vanilla Taffy
who don't like taffy unless you're you know [__]
from the modern day and age yes this is for people
to actually know what Taffy is we were born
in the oh my Taffy they got sour Berry belt
um which I've uh I've smelled the sour Berry belt
I put some of that on the other day yeah did you
feel I was followed by a thousand bees it was uh
it was good I smelled like candy people were just
like who's eating sour belly sour berries not me
because I wasn't I wasn't lying yeah my pits are
eating it yeah eating it right up stopped me from
[__] sweating and [__] you know native for
their aluminum or aluminum if you're in the UK
a free deodorant native keeps their ingredients
list bare naked kids just that we like it with
ingredients you understand like coconut oil we
all get that shea butter we all understand that
and baking soda we all I don't know what what
is baking soda normally used for do you what do
you think do they put it in bread is that what I
will say that uh tip the first word of baking soda
is what baking soda is used for Oh I thought you
said the tip like I was like that's also that
uh Native deodorant check that's a rise yes
two hour odor protection naturally derived
ingredients and a smooth residue-free application
man that's how you want it in life you want it
smooth and residue free native also offers a
variety of scents with new and limited edition
scents being released all the time uh when you
use native you will smell amazing all day long
thanks to their long lasting scents man they got
better than Common Sense Uncommon Sense want to
smell spicy and woodsy sweet or clean and fresh
well native has a scent option for everyone now is
the time to make the switch from an antiperspirant
ugh just sounds so horrible to natives that
sounds way better when you visit their site
you can discover all these fresh scents
and maybe even try out one of their body
washes while you're at it that's what
they call it not skin water skin wash
is something like a [__] serial killer uses
to treat the [__] hides of people he strips
off their bones and [__] he's like you
like to bleach your largest organ let me
be with this skin wash natives like can
you please not talk about serial killers
I love native uh it's it's my deodorant that's
what I use and for years I didn't use deodorant
until we started doing spots for Native and
I was like well can't [__] sell it unless
I know if it works start using it man I love
the [__] uh candy cane I love the gingerbread
cookie I love you know they just do sense that
makes sense sense that makes sense there it is
uh what do you what are you [__] doing watching
this show when you can be over at nativedeo.com
fat man and using the promo code Fatman a checkout
to get a sweet 20 off your first order man that's
native d e o dot com the lettersdeno.com Fatman
or use the promo code Fatman to check out for
20 20 off your first order uh that's native
deo.com kids and we thank good Folks at native
for sponsoring the show probably the last one
after I [__] jumped in with like serial killers
love this [__] if native hasn't abandoned
us yet though I don't think they ever will
they also I believe make a lavender as well
oh see there you go lavender very common kids
weed used to be calming but now I got this
I traded weed for a little bottle of [__]
Bulgarian lavender what's my problem just
do do lines of it off a stripper's ass yeah
[Laughter]
there it is uh all right we're done selling [__]
uh now we should uh talk about some stuff future
Maya Futurama yeah says I brush my teeth with
baking soda can you do that is that thing I
guess they put that in toothpaste right like arm
and ham or baking soda and they make an Arm and
Hammer [__] toothpaste did you know that Heinz
made peanut butter why that's what I thought but
I was at a place where they [__] gave me like
single peanut butter cup that you spread he opened
up and it was from Heinz and I was like they make
peanut butter as well I mean maybe they got the
whole miniaturization Tech down so this is what
do you need in a cup whatever the [__] you want
in the cup yeah so I believe it says whatever the
[__] you want in a cup I mean I ain't telling
them to like stay in your [__] Lane do ketchup
like they can do whatever they want but like
do you ever hear of Heinz doing peanut butter no
and I would have thought the ketchup would have
been a lucrative enough business to be like we'll
just be the only people who give anybody ketchup
gotta be yeah I mean the you know other
people you got the Hunts Brothers coming
in there and be like well what if we smashed
a tomato what about us what if it was cats up
yeah um go [__] yourself could you imagine like
your Heinz and you've like really conquered the
[__] condiment market and then you're
like oh by the way let's also do peanut
butter as it seems greedy that's what I'm
saying man that's why Heinz don't sponsor
this show because we're always coming down on
them always [Music] seriously [__] with eyes
uh Guillaume LaBelle and chat said Heinz Gruber
I like a little I'm 52 years old so I like
a punny word play every once in a while um
Walter he said Bic makes pens razors and lighters
fair enough I guess everyone's allowed to
make whatever the [__] they want I guess
you know I suppose the show just [__] do
you write it yeah as we all just existentially
wrestle with I guess we all should be allowed
to make whatever the [__] we yeah like what
are we [__] doing here I guess we do more than
one thing we do this you know we do [__] shows
that we write and [__] yeah look Heinz is like
[__] you you spent a lot of plates we're in
peanut butter yeah listen we just do thicker
[__] fluids and [__] and we we do spreads
if you can spread it we [__] do it leave
us alone jinx2501 said Heinz Kang sup
uh there's a good segue and we're back just to uh
Ant-Man and and the WASP colon quantumania uh Mark
sod already and talked about on the last show
and if I remember correctly boy did he love it
I was a huge fan um but I finally caught up with
Ant-Man and the WASP yes how did you feel I'm not
going to say spoilers because it's a review
so I saw somebody in check going like don't
[__] say spoilers I won't anything you want just
[__] love me um the movie opened 19 weeks ago
I honestly I I've I've I was kind of in a bad
place yesterday so I was like you know what we'll
put me in a good place going to see a good old
Marvel movie in the theaters and uh did it help
I will say this what put me in a good place was I
was I was in a I went to see it at City Walk and
when I left the theater I happen to notice
like there was a seating capacity written on
the door 86 and there were those like seats so
movie theaters are getting [__] smaller it's
mod castle like the main theater is 230 seats
then it's like the next one Down's like 175
150 120 and our smallest theater is like 98
or something or maybe 102. it's it's so crazy
um less less seats makes no sense to me but I
guess their ideas like well if it's comfier seat
you'll get people to come out uh Mike it's also
that and because I remember when I when I went
to go see Godzilla versus Kong at CityWalk and we
rented a theater and so it was like me and three
other people rented a theater go see guys over
his con there was like 20 seats in that in that
box they were all reclining seats which is great
but it was like listen if a movie's not making a
bunch of money but we still wouldn't have it in
the theater who's coming out to see it 80 people
gonna come probably not are 20 people gonna come
maybe so they just they just begin to to shrink
them even further and further and further I think
their biggest house is like 300 but then you get
down to the the tiny matchbook I was like hey it's
you and six other people enjoy it's I look as a
guy who owns a movie theater as a guy who is an
exhibitor so much so that I get to go to [__]
cinemacon at the end of April where I'm gonna
see the [__] Flash before any of yours
before you before [__] silly ass bamf man for
any of the people in this audience I get to see
flash I me [__] theater owner Kev Smith member
of NATO National Association of theater owners
um that's uh that that's that's I I'm gonna
go there's a panels it's just kind of like
Comic Con as well so I got panels one of the
panels that I want to go to is one about food
um you know because that's a big
part of the [__] film exhibition
exhibition business you don't really make
money showing movies that's for damn sure
um so I'm curious how others do it we
got uh we're very close to securing our
liquor license that we can open a bar in the
theater and [__] serve drinks and [__]
um but yeah I'm you know look I love [__] Spa
Castle Cinemas and [__] me and my friends bought
it a few months ago as I've said Ad nauseam
but this is the worst time to [__] own a
movie theater like the opening night of Creed
Three seven o'clock show we had like six people
but meanwhile for clerks open
all night packed house son
um and also mind you we didn't charge no Creed
3 price of 10 bucks that's what costs to see a
movie it's my castle 10 bucks unless you're
military then it's seven bucks um but uh you
know when we do events like like events where
I'm gonna be there we got guests and whatnot
like it was I think the clerks open
all night was 37 bucks a ticket 37
and 69 if you bought a blanket like we you know
because everyone was sleeping over more or less
um that's my secret to surviving in
movie exhibition I just charge way more
but uh I went to see it in 86 uh seat theater you
know with the [__] lie down seats and whatnot
and I'm gonna be honest like I can't give you
a complete review because I was exhausted and
I fell asleep I really have to stop falling
asleep while watching movies in a movie I've
become such an old man but the most delightful
part of it and it turned my frown upside down
and uh took care of my blues for a minute or twos
was there were kids in there like and when I say
kids I don't mean like [__] four-year-olds
and sure they sound like they were like nine
to 11 in that range Who Loved Modoc and every
time Modoc was on the screen they were [__]
laughing hysterical not in derision mind you not
going like what like just they were delighted by
the Modoc character storyline everything they
were just it was all smiles and laughter from
those kids and then after when the lights came
up all they talked about as they walked out was
Modoc they're like oh man remember when he
said like you don't always have to be a dick
or whatever and I was like did he I must have
slept through that I was like Grandpa was napping
um yeah man Modoc uh was Corey stole it was it was
pretty good I know some people were mad that it
wasn't like the real Modoc origin but I thought
it was kind of cool the way they brought him
back and made a Modoc and made sense uh the movie
itself what can I say um I liked it I mean I know
we're not meant to compare these things and stuff
but like it's not my least favorite Marvel movie
um and when I say least favorite uh you know
there's I I feel like man I don't want to get
in trouble for this but I feel like eternals was
a tougher sit for me than Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania but that being said it didn't feel I
like the first two it didn't have the same kind
of charm as the first two um the quantum realm
or as we 70s kids call it the microverse just
because they don't have the [__] rights to say
that anymore it don't mean it ain't the microverse
um was you know creative as [__] allowed for
like you know Dreamscapes and [__] like that
uh but um I don't know I I I I feel like
we probably would have fared better if
everything took place on on Earth I mean I guess
technically the quantum realm is on Earth but
in our world more so than than that world um
but uh you know what was my ultimate take on it
the utterly washable pain reading it certainly
knows how to direct a movie it's not like oh
this guy he don't know [__] um he you know he
he did it he directed he directed it better than
I ever could have but um it you know and and
I think the girl Cassie was was good although
she had one line that she just
said over and over and over
do you know what line that is um you have
to save people Dad no but no you're close
God run it was a [__] they should open that
[__] on Father's Day she said dad so much
um it felt like Hope was barely in it like I
know you know spoilers at the end she shows
up and [__] saves his ass um but uh you know
and Michelle Pfeiffer had a lot of [__] screen
time that's for sure yeah as did the Aging Michael
Douglas who just like got a laugh out of me when
he was like I love ants thank you clearly okay
um Michael Douglas that movie is is watchable
for me and I will watch it again particularly
to see the [__] I fell asleep during because
um Jonathan Majors is so [__] good I'll watch
him acting anything man like and he was it felt
like he was in a completely different movie
performance wise like he was bringing it um you
know I'm not saying like Paul Rudd didn't bring it
he was playing it you know [__] Scott Lang want
man and stuff but like Jonathan Majors can't phone
it in at least not at this point in his career
um he's [__] riveting to watch so I I was I
was there for him uh I know there was a Theory
online that Creed Three is like he's a Kang [__]
variant or something like that and when I watched
that I [__] watched it through the prison it
was like it could work at one point I was watching
Creed Three and I was like oh there's killmonger
oh there's Valkyrie oh there's Kang like see him
see you again yeah it's just a Multiverse event
there's just five actors in this business and they
all make all the movies at this point um I I liked
Modoc like I thought it was uh kind of kooky and
well done um and uh but you know hated to see
him go but you know I was there for his Arc um
it just it didn't feel I kind of agree with Mark
though it's like Kang felt like the wrong [__]
villain for this uh he has nothing to do with
Scott Lang no and no and and it's also like
you know Thanos was introduced to us
through drips and drabs and post scenes
throughout those movies and we didn't get a
full [__] Thanos movie until what Infinity War
yeah so it felt a little weird to be like well
here's your Kang movie like you know way in
advance like because you know there's a whole last
movie coming called the Kang Dynasty and we also
know he's going to be in secret Wars so I you know
I didn't understand why they would why they didn't
drip and drab them in you know I know some people
are like he was in Loki you [__] yes I know that
um but a version of him was introduced in Loki he
who remains uh it just it felt like he was way too
big and bad for Ant-Man which I guess was part
of the story right like because he kept saying
you're way out of your league Ant-Man yeah and
then Ant-Man proved somehow that he's not out of
his League but um I you know I I might have done
it a little differently I might have saved Kang
you know put a little bit of him in there in
a post scene or whatever but do you think that
was always the plan to make king the big bad
in Ant-Man or you think that came later on
I mean I think it was it was the plan for a while
because I mean they cast Jonathan Majors pretties
long ago like early in the in the
conversations about it they knew
the majors was going to be in it but it's
a point like they did nothing but setup fan
is this setting up Thanos I mean a
[__] Avengers is setting up Thanos
like you're just you're you're getting some
of the story so that by the time you actually
see Thanos it's it means something and you kind
of understand you've met his daughters who all
have like various and opposing views about what
their father is and what their father means and
and I just I kept on not being able to get a read
on what Kang wants other than to escape and to
conquer um and what does power set is like what
can can do yeah it felt like he had the all the
abilities of the of the [__] Rings like uh you
know of uh sharing cheese Rings yeah but it's like
what a ring did I fall asleep did they mention
anything about like oh I made those Rings no
abilities and [__] because yeah all of a
sudden he was like he could push Scott against
things and turn his daughter upside down which
I was like well I mean I guess that look if that
happened in the real world I'd be like yeah that
is pretty impressive but [__] Thanos could just
obliterate a [__] even without a goddamn
Stone in his hands or something like that
uh but Kang was a little bit a little bit uh you
know or his power is science based or Magic based
or yeah like because you always have the feeling
that when he was on the planet with with Janet
he was like just a guy who's charismatic and
helping to convince introduce this that whatever
but he needed her to help him fix slash get
this powered Globe so that he hours machine
but that didn't seem to be a thing that gave him
powers or not and then he still doesn't have the
power glow all over the quantum realm and has
weird-ass handy glowy things is it the armor
that gives him that like what red comet and chat
says it's future science based so there you go
glad they explained yeah I can't wait till we
get to the Future and have some of that science
everybody's just turning people upside down
and [__] like that yeah and it's also the
like Multiverse or are we doing time travel
because those are not actually the same thing
and yes I know that the [__] Quantum realm is
how Scott Lang decided that they can figure out
how to time travel but anyway I've had my say
about Kang [Music] um somebody said somebody
had a good point I'm gonna bring up uh Gabriel
Matthews in chat says watching a series of movies
where Kang gets defeated over and over is only
going to tell the audience that he is weak over
and over he doesn't feel like a big bad but like
a bunch of minions you agree with that I mean I
just don't see why you have to defeat him over
and over like I I really I said I really thought
that [__] from the trailer I thought [__]
Scott Lang was I thought Ant-Man was going to die
you know there's would continue to conquer there's
there's a there's a big part of me that thinks
that that ending was a reshoot that there's
a version of that that's like oh yeah no he's
he and either he's stuck in the quantum realm
oh he and hope are stuck in the quantum realm
and then that's how the movie ended and they
they test it to an audience they're like oh no
this is too depressing we can't just leave Scott
down there so he's got to come back he said okay
I think you're I think you're right Lloyd Sharma
says in chat there is no consequence in this movie
it would have been good to see one of the big
characters die Ant-Man or at least hope should
have died I'm with you GC is asking where's Scott
Moser and Walt Flanagan are they supposed to be
in that movie Scott I just talked to Scott I
talked to all the time Walter's in New Jersey
I don't understand that question what does that
have to do with Kang and Ant-Man I'm lost or
did he think that they were going to be on this
podcast yeah I was like what it was very strange
um yeah I I I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm curious what
what they had shot because I know they re-shot
like something you know not too long before
the movie came out that ending I think because
they had him back at a at a Baskin Robbins
somebody saw them shooting and they did me
so maybe that second Baskin Robbins bit at
the end right where he's like you're Bug Man
um DK Daniel says the last movie ended
with him stuck in the quantum Realm
yeah because that's where he is at the
start of yeah that's right that's right
yeah oh my God I forgot in the PS scene
because that's when everybody else got
dusted and then he came out in what
in endgame or Infinity war end game
end game yeah it's been game because remember
in the [__] trailers God I just I'm not
one of these cats it's like Marvel's better
[__] get back get it together and [__] but
everything was just slow pulling Taffy building
up to like Thanos and infinity War and you know
remember like [__] getting so anticipatory when
they showed like those early trailers for end
game where he's like you know it's me it's Scott
Lang I I I I'm Ant-Man we've we fought in Germany
and you know black widows or Captain America is
like when is this from and she's like is you know
it's happening right now or whatever it's just
there's they they need to get back to that kind of
Storytelling where you build that guy into a major
big bad as opposed to go like look at him look how
big and bad he is and then he gets like spoilers
the guy gets killed and I know it's like yeah well
it's just one version of Kang and there's many and
I yeah I don't I'm not saying like no audience can
follow this multiversal Tale But having a villain
that could get killed over and over and over
and I thought the big threat of Kang was that
the one we were going to meet is the one that
has killed every other king like that it was going
to be the baddest Kang Kang the [__] conqueror
there was he who should not be named there was
the Disco Kang there was all these other kings but
there's the [__] big one that they had to Exile
into the quantum Zone because he was so awful
that he was going to kill everybody else and
that's the Kang we're following if that's the case
great but it can't be crunch all you want we'll
make more kangs because then who gives a [__]
yeah yeah it's it's you know I don't know
and also like the thing that I remember
uh the the build up to end game was that it was
less I mean Thanos was a big part of that but it
was also we had been following Tony Stark for 10
15 years we've been following Steve Rogers within
15 years so when Tony had the Line This is the end
this is the end of the road that I brought us to
you know it's like oh [__] you're right like
we've been watching this personality shift we've
been watching this development for this much
time and I'm not invested in anybody really that
introduced in the last two phases you know and
when they do re-engage with the sort of Legacy
characters with Thor Ant-Man it's it's just not
quite Landing in the same way that it had before
now this is this movie um is I mean it's made
far more money than Oliver make in my lifetime
but it's not making the money it's supposed to I
guess is the complaint I mean I think it's making
more than any Ant-Man movie has made before it
no that's not true it opened bigger than any ant
movie you know movie open for it but this one
is actually going to make less I read than its
previous two incarnations that's why everyone's
writing all these think pieces and they're like
what the [__] is Marvel gonna do and stuff um I
don't know I bet you Banff man could look that up
so we're not just sitting here like
a couple dicks just saying [__]
um but I think I think the big complaint is
like it ain't even gonna do the business that
Ant-Man 2 did they spent more to make it it
did open bigger than the other two but has
dropped by 70 in its second week and it keeps
going down cocaine bear took it out and [__]
um well I mean it's it's at let's see currently
it's at 198 million dollars worldwide or just here
lifetime total so that's worldwide actually noise
that's domestic that's just domestic it's domestic
um I think last I heard struggling to get to 500.
and I don't know uh Rat GE tv says this was the
Kang that supposedly killed the version of The
Avengers yeah like because he was like are
you are you an Avenger did I kill you before
um that's the king they should have left alive
and maybe he's not dead he just got taken away
by ants did you ever see him [__] die did
he explode or whatever the [__] I don't
know but like that's the king I would have kept
around if he's meant to be like the Conqueror
the one that like you said was like the worst
Kang in the Multiverse so much so that they
stuck them in the quantum realm aka the microverse
Brian Christian chat says maybe that wasn't the
main Kang the Conqueror I guess there could be
another one I suppose anything's possible but
um yeah you're good you're a chill says me he'll
come back as the beyonder you think that's the
case I mean it's it's a beyonder because I don't
know if you just want to introduce a [__] dude
who's like I'm the beyonder um yeah I wonder what
the original ending was I wonder if like Scott
died they killed that man that would have made
it [__] Epic Man if they had to like if they
were like let's kill off Ant-Man at the end of
the Ant-Man movie yeah got his kid ready to go
right she's ready to be the young Avenger mm-hmm
I mean maybe that's what they're that's the long
game is setting Avengers that Kang Mark Kirkman
says that gang is still alive and is the threat
the Council of Kang's just banished him because
they will not kill a king right but I mean didn't
at the end of Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania I
thought the ants [__] took out Kang like first
they had the whole family ready to fight Kang
together and then [__] Incredibles looking
shot but then all of a sudden Michael Douglas
shows up with his killer ants and they took
they took Kang out that's that's
what I saw but it doesn't necessarily
mean that uh you know he's he's dead that version
of him all in the game says it's at less than 450
million worldwide Ant-Man did 519 million
worldwide and Ant-Man 2 or Ant-Man and the
WASP did 623 million worldwide so it does look
like this one's going to be the lowest grosser
I mean he needs another like 60 million dollars
Global to match the first movie which you know I
don't know if that's possible or not it you know
given how that's the most tapping the returns
have been in subsequent weeks that's a that's a
long ask I don't know if it's open everywhere yet
uh it's not Out Of Reach but you know
you expect for increased returns not
diminishing returns yeah that's the idea
this was supposed to be the biggest one
rotary dial in chat says the post-credits
scene says it all Loki season 2 will be Mega
yeah so what I don't know I don't why will it be
Mega no being another king well I mean it's yeah
I don't know I get it that everyone keeps going
the Council of Kings can't kill a king that's fine
I didn't say they should [__] kill him I'm just
asking was he killed at the End by those ants like
Dunlow says thought Ant-Man was going to
go from the goofy joke hero to a serious
self-sacrifice give my life to save everyone here
but then they clicked the button and he was back
yeah that would have been dope man if he like
if they let him like [__] sacrifice himself
at the end so it had some sort of Arc like that
didn't Kang get sucked into the infinite
possibility realm well he'll be down there
for who knows how long fighting infinite versions
of himself is that was that in the movie I didn't
notice that what I saw was a bunch of ants like
took Kang out Ken got sucked your impression
he got sucked into the machine
the cat this King and Ant-Man is from
the future from Kang Dynasty I think
he was defeated and ended up in the quantum Realm
huh what why isn't Mark Telling Kev that Kang and
Scott fought after the ants took him away did they
all right Scott and him fought well Scott was big
and he was like gang and he was breaking buildings
and [__] and Kang made a [__] energy bubble
that was protecting him and [__] but then I
just remember like Scott well Ant-Man the wasp and
and ant girl or whatever they're calling Cassie
um we're ready to show down and that's when like
the army of ants showed up uh Drew Bob wrote in
caps so this must be important he was sucked into
a wormhole after getting knocked into the core
hmm okay fair enough I I remember so little
of it because so little of this movie stuck
with me that at this point anything that
anybody tells me happened in that movie
might have happened in that movie uh Giovanni
says you need to watch the movie again dude oh
I will I [__] watch all these movies over
and over again I will never watch this Birds
to save Scott says why see the champion is
sucked into some other place Kang will return
um well obviously can we return but will
this Kang return beige Wonder says you all
are completely overthinking this you're
absolutely right but the show is fat man
beyond that's what we do here is overthink
this stuff what do you got Banff man I was
I haven't seen Ant-Man yet uh I've been scared
Away by what everybody else thinks of it but if
it's this hard I mean this isn't a Christopher
Nolan ending right like we're not watching
Inception like the fact that we have 2 000 people
in chat and no two people can agree with how this
movie ends may be part of the problem agreed now I
have some people telling me that they fist fought
like and I remember them fist fighting that's
where he's like I don't have to die or I don't
have to win you just have to lose or whatever
the [__] and he busted his helmet and [__]
uh Cassie's Mark Williams says Cassie's superhero
name is stature not Aunt girl did they say that in
the movie I don't believe so but again you didn't
say ant girl but I mean don't come at me like you
know hey man a stature if they didn't say that
in the movie I'm not gonna know that because
I believe Cassie being a part of the
ant family is relatively new in the
comics or at least new compared to when
I was reading comics on a regular basis
yeah that fight happens after the ants
so the ants come in and take [__]
Kang down and then Kang got sucked into a wormhole
and appeared in a movie that ain't right I'm
looking for real answers here stature is her name
in the comics yeah in the comics all right so
David said they didn't say in the movie I
mean I did fall asleep through a lot of it so
Kevin how do you remember it ended says
Morgan Rangel um I what I remember this is
my version the ant family was like standing
up about to stand up to him and then [__]
Michael Douglas showed up with an army
advance and then they took Kang down and then
Cassie no it was uh there's a fist fight in that
chamber where the [__] portal is which is the
last time you see him it's post ants because I
remember and that's post dance and I remember
Kang like Jonathan Majors was [__] desperate
to get to that hole and even that I was like
that's a believable performance man oh yeah he
wants that hole he wants to get to that hole um
and you know Ant-Man was stopping him from doing
it and [__] like that but I like I did I I I'm
again like I think Jonathan Majors is a wonderful
actor because I even believed that he wanted to
get the [__] out of that theater he was going
for that hole and he was like oh [__] this is my
only chance the thing I've dreamed about the whole
[__] movie so I guess yes they fought each other
but then Scott wasp shows up and pulls him
through the [__] hole [Music] yeah I don't know
yeah uh you know
to JC's point it should not be this difficult to
describe the ending of a superhero movie and now
that you'll be here movies can't be complex but
it should ultimately be an emotional resolution
and there is no emotional resolution at the
end of this movie like everything everywhere
all at once is a superhero movie it is the hardest
[__] movie to describe to anybody but I can tell
you exactly what happens at the end of that movie
because it is not about Multiverse it's not about
body hopping it's not about [__] and everything
bagel it's a mother trying to explain to her
daughter that she has [__] up most of her life
but the only good thing that's ever been a part
of it is a little bit of time that they get to
spend together and like okay again I see how that
resolves I understand what that is but like none
of the emotional tableaus of any character in this
movie gets a resolution in that final scene it's
fight fight fight I've come to save you great the
guy gets sucked into the whatever and we're back
on Earth as if nothing ever happened Zach Webb
and chat says Kang got drug off by the ants then
once Ant-Man and hope feel safe Kang shows back up
and fights them at the end and at the end of the
fight he gets sucked into the Wormhole the end
okay sure
this Kang from quantumania is the same one
we'll see in Avengers Kang Dynasty except
he defeated he's defeated and banished to the
quantum realm all right so we're going to see
Kang the Conqueror in Kang Dynasty the same
Kang who probably didn't die it looks like he
got sucked into a [__] thing he got sucked off
at the end there you go but I don't remember who
in chat mentioned but it is a weird choice to
have the guy supposed to be your big bad beaten
by the weakest superhero in the Marvel Universe
Sebastian and a hero said Ken came back without
his superpower since the ants damaged his suit I
remember that like at one point his [__] wrist
was going so he had to fight Scott just as a guy
kicking another guy's ass which like [__] again
Jonathan Majors against [__] Paul Rudd right
yeah like Jonathan Majors uh almost beat up [__]
Michael B Jordan so Paul Rudd was going to be no
problem whatsoever there's a great bit I think
it was Paul Rudd was on like Fallon or something
and he was talking about it's like well you know
who's going to win in a fight between Kang and
forget Scott Lang he's like well I'm going to show
you these two men's health covers one of which
is Jonathan majors and it's him [__] jacked
to within an inch of his life shirt off just
everything that could Ripple his Rippling it's
like and then here's me and it's just [__] Paul
Rudd wearing a t-shirt and jeans he's like they
don't ask me to take my shirt off I'm just a guy
he's a [__] Adonis and I'm just a dude wearing
[__] a gap true tan and balma chat says Kang was
sucked off into the battery that he needed for his
time ship that battery was theoretically powered
comprised of the ten Rings how is that what
is that was that a thing they never once
mentioned the ten rings and as far as we
know Xiang Chi has the 10 Rings yeah I mean last
time we saw that movie uh the ten Rings he he got
control of him right yeah I mean unless there's
a rings are us where you can just [__] pick up
some metaphysical rings in the quantum realm why
see the champ says Kang's Powers came from his
futuristic Tech Kang and Scott fight as Kang is
about to skill kill Scott hope returns blasting
him and he sucked into the battery powering the
time engine yeah that part I remember like she
came in and [__] pulled Scott out and I
guess she shot some [__] at Kang and blew
him into the battery but that don't mean he's
dead no although I don't know how it do time
battery but whatever bing bing and shot goes but
honestly what did Kang do wrong Kang was right yes
um Cali's in 132 says stop making up
the story it was a bad film well we're
just trying to figure out what happened
um allegedly Danvers says allegedly the
ten Rings kamala's bangle and Kang's Tech
are all part of the same technology foreign
said Scott says in the closing ADR that he isn't
sure if he's really dead or not yeah that part I
get so let's just go with that Kang didn't die but
he did get beaten by Ant-Man which seems a little
we've spent ending of this movie then Costner
spends at the end of JFK figuring out who
the [__] killed JFK like Daniel goes
you remember it you thought ants killed
him I'll be honest I thought my ending
was way cool the aunt struck him away
left Tomb Raider said did we touch
on how Kang vaporized people by
touching them but didn't try to
do it one single time to Scott
and the end and flow grown says the end
credits show him still alive do they
no they showed a thousand other kings yeah they
showed three other kangs then they at the very
very end they showed a old-timey earth king that
[__] Loki and Owen Wilson were like wow well
um Kang's Tyler Hall says uh Kang's
a cockroach always another one plus
someone has to be he who remains oh I get
that there are a lot of different Kings but
Dwayne Vogel says lame beaten
by the third weakest Avenger
who's the other two weaker Adventures then Skyline
we did see which is another Hawkeye fan
and black widow I suppose but then again
he came and went he came to explain for the
other weaker Avengers than Scott langwar oh
I didn't did I fall asleep on that part
god I don't remember anything anymore
you'd imagine now that I'm not smoking weed
that I'd remember everything but [Laughter]
um okay Morgan Rangel says Kevin he wasn't
defeated by Ant-Man he was tripped up by
him there's a difference excellent point one
is actually worse okay yeah Morgan Rangel to
sit there and watch movies with me all the time
so he can explain [__] he didn't get beaten
he slipped on a banana peel that left on the
ground and fell into a Time Tunnel Welcome Back
Cotter theme song uh Tana Robinson says Welcome
Back Cotter theme song greater than this movie
can why I see the champ says can kick the crap out
of everyone until Modoc and the Ants overwhelmed
him damaging his Tech when he fought Scott it
was hand to hand and he beat Scott's ass he did
all right wow I mean we may have spent more time
talking about this movie than the movie actually
the running time of the movie and a lot of people
don't believe in the 10 Rings Theory because they
were like that it was never once mentioned
go ahead Batman we should discuss esoteric
ends to every Marvel movie we've went up like
three 400 viewers so let's just keep doing it
keep more people are watching they're like yeah
same discussion Bros hey they're trying to make
sense of King come on hey kids look at Kevin
they're they're on to something he's getting
um Seattle KO said sober cab is evidently
more forgetful than THC Kevin yeah I can't
explain that Anthony M says Creed 3 isn't as
confusing let's talk about that what a great
segue thank you and we shall um uh we all
saw Creed Three Batman get in here for this
you have feelings and thoughts yeah you
must right Banff um I uh you know it's not
like it was like geez what's gonna happen but I
enjoyed the [__] out of this movie once again
I'll watch Jonathan Majors [__] do anything like
I thought he was riveting in this [__] movie as
well not just physically riveting like watching
him climb those ropes with two [__] bare hands
and [__] at one point you're in his training
but like his whole character that was the one
thing I was disappointed in about Creed 3 was they
gave away too much in the trailer because like in
the beginning like I wouldn't have seen what was
coming if it just showed up and [__] and was
like hey man I'm your old friend and [__] like
I wouldn't have known that he was coming for it
all except in the trailer he literally said I'm
coming for it all it's one of the moments where
I was like man like why why do they give so much
away I mean I guess that's how they get people in
the theater and how would you you can't you got
to show the third Act of them fighting and stuff
but I enjoyed the hell out of it I thought it
was uh well done Michael B Jordan can direct
like nobody's business man most actors who move
to directing do a really great job I find because
you've sat behind so many directors over
the course of your career Michael B Jordan
been acting since he was a kid on The Wire you
aggregate a style like you know you sit there
going well I would do that I wouldn't do that
if I was in charges but I do so by the time
they jump in there like aflac's perfect
example got sat behind a lot of [__]
directors including a lousy one like me and then
by the time he was ready to make Gone Baby Gone
a dude's like fighting like a ninja man like
he's got [__] extra sensory powers and then
by the time you get to Argo [__] yeah the
Clint Eastwood track it's the like I've been
sitting behind Masters for most of my career and
I've been asking questions and paying attention
what lenses this watch do this so when they get
the chance they've they've been to film School um
this was the they it's funny how like you know the
first two Creeds Rocky's a part of it and this one
Rocky's not a part of it all but they do reference
the Rocky fight like when they're talking about
who is Jonathan Major's character giving
him his chance they talk about like you
know nonsense Apollo Apollo gave
a little unknown guy a shot at the
title and stuff and every time they
said I was in theater like they're
thank you
um yeah I enjoyed that [__] movie although
I forgot most of Creed 2 because when the
big Russian shows up and starts sparring with
him I was like why is this a thing and then it
was like they fought in the last one did they
like what happened at the end of the last one
he just beat Drago and that was it or they
just [__] hug it out or something because
um he's he's beating the [__] out of Drago
and his father Ivan Drago throws in the towel
to save his son from dying in the ring um and it
was a whole thing where like if if the young Drago
was named my fur game I can't remember if he beats
you know adona's Creed it'll be this Redemption
story for their the entire Drogo family because
in Rocky IV when [__] Drago loses it it brings
shame to the drug ornate and his wife won't talk
to him anymore but Gene Nielsen like he's living
in the [__] like he was the pride of Russia who
then loses this fight and becomes this [__] bum
and his son was his one chance of redemption
but he had to let his son finish the fight and
so he's got to choose do I save my son's life
or do I let him keep getting the [__] kicked
out of him and bring more shame to the Drago
name and he chooses to save his son's life
um in boxing are you allowed to do this [__]
yeah yeah yeah it's not against the rules that
was new for me when he Jonathan Majors kept doing
this [__] I was like loud you're allowed to do
that in boxing I mean what it does is it exposes
your midsection like most people don't do that
because then you've got both arms up here and
all of this is wide open that guy could expose
all of that and it wouldn't [__] matter
because it's just I mean to borrow a phrase
from Rick and Morty come gutters oh my God that
guy is [__] ripped and [__] but yeah that
was the one thing I was watching going like is
it are you allowed to do this in boxing but I
guess you could do it yeah because most boxing
defensive stances are like this so that your
elbows can still be covering your rib cage while
then protecting your head but this is just yeah
whatever um the only place where I missed Rocky
though was at uh uh spoilers if you haven't seen
Creed Three the funeral scene like you would have
imagined Rocky Balboa would have showed up for
the wife's the wife of his best friend who they
must have known each other and stuff that was
the only place where I was like or even at the
fight like Rocky didn't show up at the big fight
and stuff in Dodger Stadium somebody in chat said
they didn't like the CG Stadium I didn't mind it
and one of my favorite parts of that whole third
Act was when it's just them when the stadium goes
empty and they're just fighting and you can't hear
a pin drop and [__] like I thought that was a
cool idea I didn't like the the when they brought
in the jail bars and stuff that felt a little
you could have I felt like a hat on a hat it
felt like emptying the stadium to just have
those two fighting was pretty dramatic and I
was like that's cool that's a really cool idea
it's very I mean and Michael B Jordan has been
talking about this this entire press circuit
is he's a huge anime fan and so that like the
feeling of here we are on this big busy thing
and then we just we drop everything out just
to focus on these two these two characters
and then it gets very impressionistic and very
almost like [__] film Noir and German it's
his cabinet of Dr Caligari with his giant bars
reaching to the heavens and and uh and yeah like
I I it's a it's a it's a very well directed
movie he knows what he's doing you know he
knows you know how to assemble a scene he knows
how to shoot action all invite stuff it's great
um I just I was not Creed the first
Creed is one of my favorite movies
and it it shattered me when I first saw it like I
was just in tears by the end and a couple times in
that movie I was just I was a wreck because it it
is very much about you know Adonis Creed you know
or Adonis Johnson you know trying to earn what
he feels is unattainable which is worth which is
do I deserve to be here why didn't anybody want
me you know he's been fighting his entire life
to prove that he's worthy of his last name and
so by the time you get to the end of that movie
and by the time you know you see [__] the the
quick flash of Carl Weathers is Apollo looking
at him by the time you hear that [__] music you
know you're in the bag for it you know Rocky 2 is
a little I'm sorry Creed 2 is a little bit less
emotional but like yeah like Donna still wants
a thing he's still trying to prove a thing he's
still you know there's still something to fight
for but by the time you get to this movie
like there's nothing left for him to want
and so by the time you get to the end of this
movie I was not really emotionally invested in
what was happening like yeah okay it's I guess
it's good for him to beat this old guy you know
who had taken the fall for him as a kid and now
came back and wanted everything that he had but
didn't really try to take anything like it's it's
just it's muddy emotionally by the time you get to
the end and so I'm like no I appreciate everything
that that Michael bought to it and you know yes I
will watch [__] Jonathan Mages do anything
but by the end of that movie I was not moved
um emotionally in any real way um and by the
end of the movie I was like well clearly you
know it's like you can bring this in for a
landing and of course Adonis is going to win
um I like that they hugged it out at the end so to
speak like I don't know if I believed it because
Dame was pretty pretty mad most of the movie and
then by the end he's like well apparently you did
learn some things that I didn't teach you but I
I liked it rather than it just being a narrative
about like you know these [__] hate each other
and [__] like that they fought and that's got
out of their system and yeah but what was really
beautiful was the deaf representation like the
storyline with his kid was Pitch [__] perfect
um I thought that was I thought that was so sweet
like and all and also that she was into [__]
boxing and he was like it's not about violence
it's about timing and and something else and like
being observant and [__] um but I did like that
last fight and now that you say it was put through
an anime prism that's that makes it kind of cool
[__] loved like when he [__] gut punched him
in the sweat like came off yeah oh that [__]
was they have they done that before ever not in a
Rocky movie but that's very anime that's very like
you know big climactic [__] Dragon Ball Z fight
they would do that kind of [__] all the time
um I kept on wondering I you know when they cash
out their Majors like oh he's [__] clever lags
kid right he's gonna be [__] baby clever Lang
that's what I thought and I thought I'd heard that
like when they first talked about it like that
he was going to be the young Clubber Lang or baby
Clubber Lang but apparently not apparently not but
I kept on like the more I watched them I'm like oh
well see then there's there's a really interesting
story about two sons of famous fighters whose
lives went two completely different ways you
know but you know they ended up in a [__] home
because what happens to clubber we don't know what
happens a club you can make that whole [__] up
we know what happens to Apollo you know we know
that these are two guys who are trying to earn
back the legacy of their fathers but one ended
up in jail and one ended up in [__] Bel Air
and now they're reconnecting on the other side and
then you get the idea of oh your life was supposed
to be mine in every way because my dad was also a
heavyweight champion in the world but got [__]
beat up by that white guy like my Dad should
have left me everything but he ended up a [__]
whatever he lost it all gambling whatever that was
he died penniless and broke it's like you supposed
to have I'm supposed to have what your life is
and now I want it as opposed to the weird like
kind of subjective like oh well you just did
well for yourself I wanted to be a boxer too
so I was a golden gloves and now you're
a boxer and that sucks everyone in shot
is talking about uh Dragon Ball Z that was a
Dragon Ball Z punch where the [__] you hit
somebody in the Smoke comes off the back
mark C in chat said then making up at the
end was okay with me because it felt like Dame
realized he didn't just get given his life his
winning shows that Adonis deserved and worked
for it yeah yeah I buy that absolutely um well
put yeah yeah so wait do you do they do another
Creed well they're now launching a Creed verse
coming out of retirement again well I know
they had a they had a Drago movie that was
in development about the Drago kid um
I think they have plans to do something
with his daughter who is clearly training
to be a boxer um they're talking about a
rocky origin story although I'm pretty sure
Rocky one was an origin story so I don't know
what what origin there is like oh when he was a
[__] Lake breaker for the mob okay I suppose
um but yeah MGM is very much about like given the
success of Creed 3 and given the investment that
Michael B has with it like we want to build it out
into its own Suite of movies and TV shows Creed
yeah because he's a huge anime
yeah so I'm down with that
um if they do one more Creed then they should like
do the clever Lang story I think that'd be cool
yeah I mean because after a while it's like yes
I understand that it's you know we'll we saw them
do with Drago how many times you're gonna go
back to the old Rocky movie well for bad guys
or the same token it's what we're here for guys
very true man what'd you think about Creed Three
Creed one I watched Creed on the plane
the first one on the plane on the way
to Austin and I still I've seen it 20 times
it's one of my favorite movies of all time
uh and I did I got like teary eyed like
four different times watching that movie
um and I didn't care like I didn't care
emotionally about anything in Creed Three
the way that I did in Creed one or
Creed 2. and I think it really missed
like one of the things that's so great
about Rocky is that like even in Rocky
5 that everybody hates that's the one where he
gives the speech to his son that is so mimified
where it's like nobody's gonna hit you as hard
as life like it's not about how hard you get
it's not about how hard you hit it's about
how hard you get hit and keep going forward
that's in like the worst of the Rocky movies
and I felt like this movie didn't have that
big moment it didn't have kind of that Rocky four
moment where he gives the speech at the end which
for the time that movie came
out was like when the you know
Soviets were like the biggest bad guys on
Earth and Sylvester Stallone is cheesy and
whatever as it is it's like saying like hey
can't we all just get along um so I think I
really missed that I really missed like is there
an opportunity to like spend more time with like
Adonis and his daughter and he gives his daughter
that speech it's not just like the one sentence
it's like more of a crescendo I think I would
have liked to see uh more Jonathan Majors on
Muscle Beach Montage like that could have been
really cool and I feel like it was truncated a lot
um I just didn't I I thought it was really well
directed for a first-time director I was amazed
but like emotionally it was I think it was the
most stagnant of mid of all the Creed movies
oh my God you're [__] you're the new
Mark Bernardin [__] with your little
honestly I thought they had a really interesting
opportunity because I think to your point JC
that what made the Rocky movies great when they
were great is that Rocky lost more than he won
you know and so there's always a hill for him
to climb whether that hill was in the ring or
whether the hills out of the ring but then
they had an opportunity and they they kind
of glanced up against it talking about mental
health in the black community which you know
I'm not going to say is non-existent but it's
definitely not encouraged um historically for
men to talk about their feelings to talk about
their how they're broken and to try to do the
work to put themselves back together you know
and so the idea that that Adonis still carries
all of the trauma of growing up without a dad
or thinking that he was abandoned of trying to
prove his worth of now having a kid who you know
so much of Rocky 2 is about him not being able
I'm sorry Creed 2 was about him struggling with
engaging with it with a deaf child and what that
means to have a to have a kid with a disability
you know all of that stuff is is Weighing on
him and now comes this this again an old trauma
you know the guy who went to prison in his Stead
you know to have the real breakdown and to have
the real putting himself back together like I know
you got to have a [__] running up a hill but
you know the real montage is that guy learning
to get in touch with himself that is actually a
champion that he's kind of pushed to the side and
kicked to the curb for most of his life you know
and it it was one of a couple of things that felt
interesting but never explored in that movie like
I kept on expecting [__] Dame to make a run at
Tessa Thompson because like he's connecting with
her he's like the way is wonderful in the movie
as well she's she's great until she has nothing
really to do yeah you know when she because it
gets interesting when he's like well what does it
feel like to watch somebody else sing your songs
and she's like well I don't know like I just had
to make a choice that my hearing was losing and
I had to how much time do I have left being
able to hear and do I push it by singing and
Performing even though I know it's not right do
I try to still make music and I'm compromising
on what I thought was my gift like that's a real
connection point for both of them like how much
time do I have I'm 35 years old I just come out of
prison I want to be Champion I've been watching my
life slip away you know and then there's a guy
who seems to not understand what he has in front
of him like that's that's a club relationship hey
woman you know how to handle that shot like why
don't you come over here have a real man like I
just I wanted more of him engaging like breaking
apart adonis's life Brick by Brick like I took
away your Champion I [__] with your your big
fight I'm taking away your money I got your girl
I convinced your your kid to start fighting in
school like I blew up your whole [__] spot
and now I have this belt what are you gonna do
and there's a great opportunity there to
give Tessa Thompson the speech that brings
him back that rallies him that gets him
through the end fight that she never gets
like she you know I understand why somebody in
chat was like without Stallone none of it works
and I I don't believe that yeah I like Stallone
in those movies but I think this movie worked and
you know even without Stallone in it but like give
tessitation Mark anywhere right it was missing a
bit of emotion go ahead get give her that moment
let her be the inspiration now that gets him up
when he doesn't think he can stand up um it
doesn't need to be Sly anymore but you didn't
do any of like you didn't give us that
um it made me want to watch Rocky 3 again
you should have never came back hey woman
hey woman I wanna I wanna do the voice so
bad but I don't think I'm allowed anymore when
we were kids we could all do [__] Club online
but now I feel like I'd get clipped and memed
and destroyed on the internet for trying to do
a version of color line but it's Kevin Smith
doing Mr T cultural appropriation of the worst
kind but it uh I love that [__] scene Mr T
is so [__] unbelievably great in that movie
like his screen did I think he was in DC cab
before that maybe maybe it was a car wash it's
it's one of those like weird early 80s relics
but like that's his big [__] move it's Rocky
three one of the best movie villains of all time
so great he's so antagonistic uh well I see the
champion chat said Creed 3 is a straightforward
streamline feature that delivers exactly what
it's selling the film is an utterly predictable
tale told extremely competently and you love it
for its directness that reads like a [__]
legit review right there yeah like and I I
would have no problem with Creed Three and
I don't really because again it was to have
a huge problem with if there hadn't been a
Creed one like if I hadn't known how good
it could be then I wouldn't be that upset with
how kind of just right up the middle Creed 3 is
uh will Wilkins said Creed 3 is the anti-antman
we all know what happened at the end of that
yeah did they actually leave the stadium or
let's just get into it is is Dane dead yeah the
whole time he's a phantom uh ghost day says it's
not missing Stallone as the actor it's missing
him as a filmmaker he puts all those things
that are missing in the movie The Emotional
Drive is always present in his Rocky movies
um yeah I mean I don't think It suffers for
lack of Stallone's touch but he's right in
all those Rocky movies you know remember
her in Rocky 2 where she's in the hospital
and she's like win Rocky win and he's like
why don't we for him I can still do him so
March you can't do Mickey but I can do
Mickey so yeah it goes both ways for me
welcome to my black privilege
the one thing I can do
three totally watchable flick you're if you're
into boxing movies totally check it out and I
think I think the kid did such a great job kid I
mean he's man now but uh Michael B Jordan did a
[__] great job directing it um but Jonathan
Majors [__] [__] that dude gives like his
performance in Lovecraft country is different
than his performance as Kang is different than
his performance as Dane like this guy's like
a legit wonderful actor yeah I really want to
see magazine Dreams the movie what is that yeah
I heard about it in Austin for the when we were
there for the awards ceremony somebody was like a
magazine dream is gonna be huge what is it about
um he plays a bodybuilder um I don't I
don't is it the story like of the like
is it based on a true story I don't know I I know
so little about it and I think they're keeping it
kind of close to the best because it went to
Sundance and won a bunch of stuff got picked
up out of Sundance by by Fox Searchlight I think
but but apparently he's great and it's it's also
a physical transformation movie it's while I'm in
this good of shape while I look this way and then
and can maintain it I'm gonna take my shirt off as
much as I [__] can and so I think he's playing
a bodybuilder who wants to be better but whatever
whatever and I'm not entirely sure but [__] it
again we'll watch that dude do anything he was
an Army commercial uh when I went to go see uh
um kylo Ren hits dinosaurs today and he was just
like I'm [__] look Jonathan may just talking
about how cool the Army is which whatever
but like you're good in this commercial
the um we interviewed them at Sundance
Jonathan majors and uh the director of
the magazine dreams movie and it struck me
as uh tonally like the wrestler the Mickey
Rourke Wrestler movie but instead of somebody
at the end of their career it's somebody kind
of more towards the beginning but is
obsessed with uh the celebrity of it
sounded really interesting I'm in
dude's got incredible [__] range
um somebody said something here Saul Good said
Lovecraft country came out same time as the latest
Terminator movie and I remember thinking man they
could have had him as the newest Terminator what
a Miss is that true they were going to maybe cast
him as a Terminator that I don't know I I sort of
feel like that's a complete waste of his talent
because he's gonna say like [__] this guy's
got incredible range like don't he don't need to
play a robot I think a man's robot robot um I'm
gonna hit 65 real quick yeah let's hear it Mark
saw 65 Kids Adam Driver versus dinosaurs with
lasers kylo Ren hits Dennis right now playing
its mod Castle Cinemas if you want to go see it
um it is it's a it's a fine down the middle old
school kind of Creature Feature science fiction
movie like it's and it's also a bit of Lone Wolf
and Cub and that you know Adam Driver plays a a
guy with a with a terminally ill kid who takes
this two-year mission to get enough money to pay
for a kid's treatment in the middle of the mission
[__] goes wrong hit by an asteroid field and
crash lands on dot dot dot Earth in 65 Million
BC and so in order for him to escape this planet
and rescue the girl who's in the the only other
Survivor this accident he's going to Traverse
the Wild and do battle with [__] dinosaurs um as
such you know exactly what this movie is going to
be it's a couple of jump scares it's a couple of
survivaly things it's a couple of uh dislocated my
shoulder and a weird not as I was encroaching
will I get my gun fast enough yes he will
um but you know it's [__] Adam Driver who's
like a very good actor yeah there's another
guy with [__] range put him and Jonathan majors
in a movie together hell yeah reading the [__]
phone book and you'll get you'll get something
worth watching man two of them are incredible
actors yeah I mean he's he's much better than this
movie is but this movie is just it's right down
the middle um This was um uh tsg and um Braun
I think which is um Matthew Vaughn's company
um yeah like it's and it was it was written and
directed by the guys who wrote a quiet place
and so it has a lot of that kind of very
Elemental kind of like here's a here's a
here's a problem we're gonna make our character
solve here's some difficulties we're gonna give
him and also oh yeah by the way there's monsters
hiding in the [__] Forest um so yeah like it's
I it does not reinvent anything it is not an
antidote to sliced bread um but if you want
to spend like you know an hour and 45 minutes in
the the foresty Wilderness while Adam Driver and
a little girl attempt to survive dinosaur attacks
go for it some would be put that quote on a poster
it's all good corrected me just by saying it was
just a dream casting for the role of Terminator
it's not he'd heard that Stephen Bruce says
Kevin I just want to let you know that this
is the best I've ever seen you look why thank
you Stephen Brew means the world Stephen Brew
wants to get to like second base he wants
to get pushed in the hole that Quantum hole
um now have you are you caught up on Mando Kevin
now I have not watched uh uh the second episode
I saw episode one but I haven't seen the second
one yet what we could do here's what I'll suggest
um let's see my kid I'm we've been doing this for
two hours and I'm supposed to go eat with my kids
so what I suggest is we hold our news that we were
gonna do today for Friday's show okay um Friday in
case you come in late kids you're like what do
you mean Friday's show uh me and Mark will be
doing fat man beyond live from smodcast Castle
Cinemas in Atlantic Highlands as we bring the
Ides of Mark Festival to a close man Mark's coming
out and we're showing three 80s classic 80s movies
Dune is on Wednesday night go get tickets right
now it's mycastlecinemas.com or ceasemont.com
Streets of Fire is on Thursday night tickets
available at cspod.com or smodcast tocinemas.com
then Flash Gordon's on Friday night and then
after Flash Gordon we're doing fat man beyond
for the very first time from Smart Castle Cinemas
for the very first time on the East Coast together
um so that episode is where Mark will talk about
the last of us is that what it's called indeed
um the season finale and uh uh we'll do all
the news that we're not doing here yeah and
we can do Mendo episodes two and three because
we'll have three out then I will have seen yes
oh that's when is it why when's the new one drop
Wednesday I think oh perfect all right so then
we'll do Mando two and three and then we'll be
doing Q a as well but we'll take in the questions
from people in the audience that time right um so
yes Friday night kids we're gonna do this again
this is just a little taste this is just a
tease [__] showing a little nipple that's all
did you see that I was almost whipping my title
I know what the [__] man Stephen Brew said that
I looked good and I was like maybe I looked
showing nipple good yeah put them on a glass
that's what Friday's show is gonna be all about
putting them on the glass kids uh so if you're
not in the New Jersey area New York New Jersey
Pennsylvania area if you're not on the East Coast
um you'll be able to watch Batman Beyond as we
stream it right from Spa Castle Cinemas but if
you're on the East Coast well why the hell
wouldn't you be in the room where it happens
the room where it happens to borrow a phrase
from a [__] Broadway popular New York area
Entertainment yes um yeah man it's gonna be all
sorts of Good Times uh and we haven't done it
with an audience in a minute when was the last
time we did with an audience to at uh coming
villain August of last year maybe bamf yeah it'll
be more responsibility shows coming up though as
well kids uh for in fact we should book one soon
uh after the odds of Mark I come back on back to
Los Angeles on September 18th Mark is going to
be doing a signing at Jay and Silent Bob's secret
stash on Saturday the 18th which costs nothing
[__] free for nothing Jumping On a Plane he's
going to be uh signing whatever you want but
he's signing primarily uh Adora in the distance
um so put that on your calendar Saturday uh
March 18th Mark Bernardin at Jane Silent Bob's
secret stash right there in Red Bank New Jersey
I will be on a plane to get back to Los Angeles
to do Hollywood Babylon with Ralph at Flappers
tickets at cspod.com but then I'm back in Los
Angeles for like two weeks during which time
we should probably try to do a Cantina show yep
um we can try are you going away are you staying
back East for a minute um no I'm I'm I'm I'm on
a plane that night on the 18th I'm here for
all of the week of the 20th the 24th and then
I'm in New Orleans for the uh Overlook Film
Festival I'm bringing Splinter to New Orleans
oh and that's the other thing we should probably
tease just a little bit yeah we may or may not
be showing splinter after the fat man Beyond
podcast sounds like a Yes sounds like a distinct
possibility kids what are you waiting for don't
sleep on this [__] don't you sleep on fat man
beyond live from [__] smart Castle Cinemas
on Friday because it sounds like you may get
a splinter a splinter or the whole damn thing
you can't see it online he ain't gonna stream
it online so like if you're like oh will we see
it no you're gonna have to see it live in person
but wait let's go back to New Orleans so you're
showing it at a festival there the Overlook Film
Festival which is uh they build themselves as
the greatest horror film festival in the country
um and so yeah very excited our second our second
Film Festival appearance um folks and look at that
folks you can see it [__] you could either
see it in New Orleans New Orleans as they say
locally or you might be able to see splinter
in New Jersey out of real ass movie theater
owned by a real ass Movie Maker Kevin Smith's
my castle Cinemas and stuff uh Jack and Chad
is asking uh JC do you sell food at the Cantina
[__] yeah you do we do very good food yeah they
do markers devouring last two weeks ago I was I
bombed in I I played [__] trivia at the Cantina
did pretty well for a person who doesn't study
uh Jay Graham is saying Kevin any chance you'll
sell online tickets to watch some of the special
q and A's at this mod Castle live you don't even
have to buy a ticket to watch fat man beyond you
can watch it Friday night it's gonna be happening
right there some mod Castle Cinemas um the uh
we also got coming up I think it's March 31st
uh Brian Quinn is bringing in practical jokers the
movie to Smart Castle Cinemas and uh we're going
to show that and chit chat afterwards and stuff
um I don't know if we're streaming that or not but
I'll find out uh but yeah I honestly like if we
stream stuff I don't know that we'll charge for it
like I think we'll just kind of put it up on the
YouTube channel and stuff because it acts the free
commercial for the for the theater at the very
least but we're not gonna [__] show Splinter
that's not gonna happen you got to be live in the
room yes we will cut the fat man feed and then
show whoever's in the house a short if if you guys
are not on the East Coast this weekend however
we are opening early on Friday the 17th
for St Patrick's Day you can uh you can
come get some green beer and pretend you're
Irish with us but banshees of inner Sharon
but more exciting than that is every the weekend
after St Patrick's Day so Saturday March 18th
uh we celebrate sir Patrick's Day Sir
Patrick Stewart's day so uh cheap green
beer to celebrate uh Sir Patrick we're gonna do
Patrick Stewart trivia and uh a bunch of X-Men and
um and Star Trek drinks to celebrate you know
the geek icon Patrick Stewart and before we uh
even started the show you were talking about
you're on the Star trek.com website for what
was that we are we are doing on March 24th which
is super exciting we're doing an official Star
Trek strange new worlds event which is uh we're
going to be doing trivia with cast from the show
um this is a flyer from the Star
Trek website which is so exciting
uh prizes presented by Paramount that shit's
official Yeah official official official
star trek.com um so we'll be doing that on March
24th on Friday it is uh open to the public so you
can come in and and hobnob with uh real Star Trek
people and tester Star Trek knowledge we have the
uh Chateau Picard wine that we will be serving
so if you ever wondered what Jean-Luc Picard's
wine tasted like we've got a case of that we'll
be serving and it looks like we have the official
Romulan ale that we will have as well it's
banned in the Federation but you can get it
at scum and villainy cantina uh so really
cool uh Star Trek stuff coming up as well
whether you're into treks or Wars uh the scum
and villainy cantina is the place for you man
scum and villainy cantina right there in Hollywood
in the heart of Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard
you are you open seven nights a week seven nights
a week and then we open at 11 A.M uh for lunch on
Saturday Sunday Black Belt Jones and chat said
the grilled cheese at the Cantina is awesome
awesome he said do you uh if you're
casting about JC for Star Trek trivia
questions one of them could be what uh what
podcast do you may or may not know and love
um is now officially a member of the crew of
the USS Titan on Picard and that would be me
I'm I'm was name checked as Ensign Bernardin on
episode 4 of Star Trek the card wow look at you
man yeah the [__] PA calls for me to report
to the deflector control room I was like huh
down the show correct I worked on season two
I didn't I had no part of season three other
than apparently now I'm I'm enlisted in
Starfleet you are man you're a member of
starfully you're part of the continuity and
[__] absolutely do you have a page on the
Star Trek Wikipedia like the Star Trek version of
Wikipedia somebody needs to create that somebody
needs to put that in there internet you guys do
you guys want one of our um our sir Patrick's Day
trivia questions we'll see if you can get
it yeah let's go let me hear one all right
so I'm gonna get I'm gonna read you a line
of dialogue and you need to say whether it's
Professor Xavier or Jean-Luc Picard oh this is
fun I might be able to pull this off go ahead
buried deep within you beneath all the years of
pain and anger there is something that has never
been nurtured the potential to make yourself a
better man Picard that is that's that's Xavier
talking about Logan that is Jean-Luc Picard are
you kidding me isn't that wild that is wild man
so I've got a bunch of stuff like that to make
you win the trivia are there prizes or no there
will be try prizes for um for sir Patrick's Day
trivia will be bar credit and then uh paramounts
bring in the cool stuff for the 24th for that
Star Trek trivia look at that man all right so
there you go come to the scum and villainy cantina
kids and get your [__] serve Pat stew on [Music]
um eating that [__] serpat stew uh what is his
date on that uh sir Patrick's Day is uh on March
18th this year and the strange new world event is
strange new worlds sorry event is on Friday March
24th and don't forget uh this week is the Ides
of Mark right out here in uh well not here in New
Jersey uh at smog Castle Cinemas Mark showing
you uh Dune David Lynch is doing on Wednesday
night streets my name is a killing word that's
right man more deep my name is a killing word uh
Streets of Fire on Thursday night and Flash Gordon
on Friday night followed by the debut of fat man
beyond right there at uh smodcast Castle Cinemas
and then Saturday in the afternoon I think it
starts at noon or 11. Mark is going to be at Jay
and Silent Bob's secret stash 20 years in business
as a brick and mortar kids I will sign whatever
you put in front of me you pull your [__] dick
in front of Mark he'll tag it and [__] yeah
yeah I mean you need to pull it I won't hold
it yeah he ain't gonna touch your dick that'd be
weird but he'll sign it I'll show you that [__]
uh uh and it'll be back in Los Angeles here uh
uh March 18th for Hollywood Babylon at Flappers
comedy club with Ralph Carmen somebody asked in
chat they're like do you live in Jersey or Los
Angeles uh the answer is both with with a bof both
I live in both uh so I'm splitting I'm now because
of the theater I spent a lot of time in Jersey
obviously so we're splitting time between both
Coast kids so I'm doing a show here doing a show
there for for years for about 20 years straight
it was all shows in Los Angeles and people on
the East Coast were like what about us well
now I'm doing shows there and doing shows here
man by Coastal and buy kids because it's hip
[__] trendy to be by so I'm bi-coastal and
I'm bringing my bio Coastal buddy Mark Bernardin
for the odds of Mark that's Montego Cinemas and
then to do a big old signing at Jay and Silent Bob
secret stash what do you think come out and visit
uh tickets available at csmod.com or Flappers
comedy club or just show up to scum and villainy
cantina you ain't got to buy no tickets and stuff
you do got to buy some drinks is there like a
drink minimum it's coming villainy bamf man JC
bamf uh no you can come in and buy a single
root beer and sit there all night just hang
out get your geek on for those of you who can't
be at the scum of villainy Cantina or can't be
it's modcastle Cinemas uh don't forget we're
streaming fat man beyond on on uh Friday night
uh during that episode Mark's going to review the
end of the season finale of Last of Us we'll talk
about mandalorians episodes two and three
because three will be up uh by that point
and uh we'll do all the news that we didn't do
here and if you're in the room as soon as the
credits roll on fat man beyond well [__] we're
gonna give you a splinter right in your dick
that's kind of Splinter best planner
to get dick Splinter the private eye
show that Mark and I will be doing next yo have
you watched any of Poker Face not yet how is it
I hear it's wonderful procedural it's like Colombo
it's very Colombo so Colombo in fact that when you
get to the end of watching Poker Face on peacock
you know how it you know it'll always cue another
program to come up next what comes next after
Poker Face is episode one season one of Colombo
is that right yeah which which was a
really interesting watch because the
first episode of Colombo ever was written
by Stephen bochko and directed by a young
lad named Steven Spielberg what yeah he'll
go far you know he's got a future I think
um kids have you enjoyed yourselves well if you
did it's because of these two guys man give it
up for Banff man uh and give it up for The Man
Without whom there is no fat man beyond you'd
imagine it's me but no I'd be doing anything
else you know me I [__] always trying to be
in your face and [__] smear my brand all over
the corporate landscape the only reason there's
a fat man beyond is because good old Mark
Bernardin is the only one with the balls to
actually tell you what he thinks about Ant-Man
and Creed going out on a limb uh there it is
don't forget Friday we're doing this again man if
you're sitting there going what [__] Friday no
that's when I go out and drink well may I suggest
you sit in and drink and watch us do this [__]
wonderful show where we're to talk about all the
culture that pops right here on fat man beyond
Man tickets for all that other [__] happened in
New Jersey cspod.com kids don't forget hopefully
we'll see you there man we need some help on
the Streets of Fire I'll be honest with you
has been the toughest cell man I keep
chalking it up to a Thursday night but
you got to convince people so that's why I keep
saying it stars the Snyder versus Martha Kent
which is either a draw or a warning uh
there it is my friends uh there's your
fat man beyond there's your [__] fat
man beyond for tonight uh for fat man
beyond I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark Bernard
tune in next time kids same fat Time same
fat channels modcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss everybody [Music]
yeah this is the cat greetings
everybody and welcome to the
AKA ask Kevin every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and this
is what happens with Jay and Silent
Bob get old off Kevin Smith [Music]